hi I'm Evan Carmichael and today I'm
going to answer your question for one of
my readers Felicity felicity is an
Australian entrepreneur she runs an
online business and she's asking about
how to create a newsletter without
spending a monthly charge to pay a
company to help her with it
so a newsletter is a great idea for any
entrepreneur if you have customers who
bought from you in the past they're more
likely to buy from you again if they had
a good experience and enjoy buying from
you so it's a great way to stay in touch
and send them new offers to do it
without spending any money how I first
did it was I'd do a mail merge between
Excel Office and outlook so you store
all the names of your contacts in Excel
you create your newsletter in Word and
then you can combine it to a mail merge
to send it up through your elbow this
may be a great way it's really cheap
doesn't cost you anything except we're
buying Microsoft Office which most
people have there are problems with it
though something to think about as your
newsletter list grows you could be
limited by how many emails you can send
per hour I found out with my internet
service provider it was 700 so once I
sent that 700 emails in an hour I'd get
locked off and people think that you
might be spamming the other thing to
think about is if you then want to move
to a new service so I use Aweber as an
example I think there's a $1 free trial
and there's $19 a month to get started
so minimal investment but I think worth
it to invest into your business to move
people from an excel file into Aweber
they're gonna have to opt in again so
you're gonna lose a lot of people
through that process it's better to get
started from the beginning using a
software tool the other thing I really
like about a weber is they'll give you a
spam filter scores so every email that
you
now they'll tell you the likelihood that
they'll get caught in the spam filters
of your customers and give you tips for
how to get out of changing different
words around and changing your layout so
the equipment do any easy way not
spending any money is to do the mail
merge with Excel Word and outlook if you
want to see how that's done just leave a
comment below and I can do a quick
tutorial on how to do it it's pretty
easy once you get started but I would
recommend thinking about the long term
for your business and trying to make a
little bit more investment in your
company and building an email newsletter
list through a software program like
Aweber or another company because it
can't have a serious impact on your
business and it's worth the investment
in my opinion anyway I hope that helped
if you have any questions please leave a
comment below I'd also love to hear your
your thoughts and feedback and please
give the video a thumbs up and we'll
stay tuned to the next episode
you